disclaimer i owe nothing
spider-man far from homecoming 2 take me
home country roads finally released its
first trailer
and i've been dreading it for months not
because the trailer was bad
in fact it looked pretty awesome and i
liked a lot of things from it
but god do i hate being on social media
whenever mcu spider-man becomes relevant
again because
no one knows how to have any civil
discourse about this vision of the
character
it was maybe 10 minutes after the
trailer dropped that i'm just seeing
people fight about it again
i was hesitant to talk about this
trailer because i know mcu spider-man
has easily one of the most
rabid and quick to anger fan bases i've
ever seen
bear in mind if you're just a fan of mcu
spider-man and you act like a rational
respectful sane person who understands
other people can have different opinions
then i'm not talking about you you're
cool i'm talking about the psychos on
twitter who post 20 things a week to say
anyone who dislikes or criticizes the
film is an idiot
the people who just ooze this gross smug
aura about how
superior their opinions are and rant
endlessly about why you're not a true
spider-man fan if you think this series
has flaws
i think some of the most unpleasant
experiences i've ever had online were
talking to people about this movie
i've had people insult me insult my
appearance poke fun at my less than
stellar financial status
write long essays about why my opinion
is wrong and ill-informed despite having
read just about every ongoing comic with
this character's name on it
or being told that the comics don't
matter and i need to just let it go when
things have changed
so mcu spider-man despite absurd amounts
of evidence to the contrary
is the quote-unquote most comic accurate
spider-man ever
but also comic accuracy doesn't matter
it's a new take stop living in the past
whichever one makes me sound wrong at
the time is true i guess [ __ ]
consistency
so with all that out of the way i have
some mixed opinions about homecoming
and i'm really desperate for far from
home to evolve the character a little
and fix some of those issues
there are some parts of it that i can
confidently say that i loved and some
others i can confidently say let me down
but the trailer seems to give me a lot
more things to love about this one for
one thing this trailer gives us a small
glimpse into tom holland's peter parker
being more reluctant to be a superhero
after so many scenes of him getting
excited to suit up for an adventure in
the first one he takes one look at this
suit here and gets like this haunted
look and then opts to leave it behind
on his trip to europe reminds me of a
story where he goes to europe without
his suit then realizes he needs it after
his co-worker ned leeds has his throat
slit
so he goes to a costume shop in germany
and badly explains that he needs a
spandex bodysuit for 30 minutes in
broken german
only for the store owner to announce in
english that the only thing like a
spandex bodysuit in stock is this
yeah look at that anguish and emptiness
that's the peter parker way so tom pete
just kind of brushes it off like nah i
want to have a fun vacation but you know
something deeper is going on here
speaking of deep things peter finally
has a new love interest in michelle jane
michelle didn't really do anything in
the first movie except a
sunderray and say things that pissed off
half of the political spectrum
but i liked what little she did
contribute to the movie
one of my big complaints of homecoming
is that mj wasn't in it enough
i get there they're going for a really
different take on her to distinguish her
from dunstcap and game of stones
and i'm all for that you see i like
changes to the source material when i
can see
and understand why they did it and i can
see potential for it telling a new and
interesting story
i don't think peter and this mj have an
amazing chemistry and are the perfect
superhero couple yet like some people
but i'm willing to let this one change
that for me i'm also
totally fine with peter getting out of
new york for a bit we've had plenty of
movies with him in the city already
and there's tons of examples from the
comics of him visiting other cities or
countries
it'll be a lot more fun to see him
swinging around new locations for once
look no one ever said it has to be a
one-to-one recreation of the comics and
use the panels as storyboards
in fact some comic movies are good
specifically because they're
so inaccurate thanos had a completely
new character motivation
miles morales had a different
personality iron man had a sense of
humor
changes are necessary and important to
make sometimes the source material just
sucks and needs some retooling and being
in the comics doesn't automatically make
an idea good
the thing i'm looking for is the same
spirit or same
tone as the original story unless of
course that tone
sucks basically just adapt the good
parts ugh after they get their temporary
digs in europe ned gets assassinated by
apache the pirate now we see peter
recruited by shield to take down some
new villains
sandman molten man and hydra man maybe
or they're the elementals in which case
they're
magnum hellfire or hydron
because that's an important distinction
i'm a lot more excited for the action
scenes in this one
i really can't see how they can screw
this up these monsters are huge and
these set pieces are so elaborate and
cool
homecoming had really underwhelming and
unimpressive action sequences where
spidey was tripping all over himself or
just
wouldn't do anything beyond web people
up this character is one of the
strongest and fastest fighters in all of
fiction
so he just felt poorly utilized but i'm
sure those people
you know the ones are already hammering
at their keyboards to say the fights
were supposed to suck
because it's a small scale spider-man
story and they're underwhelming and
unimpressive because that's the point
which makes perfect sense because the
movie immediately after it and before it
contained vast amounts of spider-man
kicking ass
he just forgot all that forward thinking
and super strength for this middle
section here
because he's inexperienced it's not that
the director didn't know how to do
action scenes with this much cgi
but maybe he'll be less inexperienced in
this one now that he's already fought
thanos hand-to-hand and i'm sure if the
action sequences are in the same level
as homecoming someone will come up with
an elaborate excuse for that too
he can't fight as good now because he
has ptsd
and thinking of doing sick backflips and
punching people makes poor baby peter
afraid
speaking of being afraid i think
mysterio looks really cool and i hope
this movie will dispel the amount of
stupid people thinking that his powers
are the same as scarecrow
no he can't make peter relive the death
of uncle ben over and over
no he can't make peter hallucinate his
disintegration on titan
quentin beck is a hollywood effects guy
and stunt man everything he does is
technology based
like holograms magnets costumes and
robots and so on
he wouldn't be able to recreate any of
peter's tragic memories unless he had
intimate knowledge of what those events
look like it's not like he's gonna sit
peter down and go
hey just for no particular reason what
are your greatest traumas in life and
can you provide a transcript of
everything
said during them as well as a photo of
the location from multiple angles
anyway i'm glad they kept his helmet and
i like that he's trying to pretend to be
a hero by going after the bad guys
either these are illusions he's creating
with random alien tech that wound up on
earth or these are just some bad guys
with powers that he hired to take a fall
so his superhero persona looks good
maybe spidey will get a little too
trusting of him and look up to him as a
new potential father figure since
uncle iron man is probably dead by this
point only for it to blow up in his face
i also think i'm in a minority among a
lot of spidey fans when i say this but
this suit is really cool
and i like the red and black color
scheme sure it evokes more of a miles
morales feel but so do a lot of things
about this version of spidey
and that's not a bad thing it's just a
thing not everything is a jab
last up i gotta talk about the little
things that i appreciate from this
trailer
avengers tower being heavily renovated
in the back and i have a feeling that
it's going to be a big plot point for
the mcu
spidey can actually swing around tall
new york buildings again with relative
ease
so i assume going to space helped him
get over that fear of heights
aunt may seems to be running a version
of the feast shelter as seen recently in
angsty man ps4
and flash thompson is acting pretty much
how he did in the comics
i always love that weird irony where he
loves spider-man but hates peter parker
i wish they brought that up in the other
movies a little more
i'm keeping my expectations low because
i have a feeling this will be no
spider-verse
what i'm looking for is just a little
more gravitas and emotional weight
spider-man stories are supposed to have
a dark undertone masked by the fun and
excitement
being a superhero sucks most the time
and peter parker feels like he's getting
put down by life in every way imaginable
the first movie lacked that weight
consequence and drama
it's been talked about to death by this
point and elaborated on a lot more by
people who care more than i do
if this sequel can deliver on that
emotional core and sell that spider-man
tone
then it'll be a great step up for
peter's character development and it'll
feel more true to the character from
those rags we all collect
the emotion is right then some of the
other stuff like action scenes matter a
lot less to me
i think compelling story takes the most
important role
and i'm willing to let it do that you
know what maybe i figured out these
movies are awesome if you just
disassociate spider-man from them
entirely and stop
expecting spider-man stuff in them we
got the animated movies for that now
i'll just pretend it's a heavily
derivative yet legally distinct
off-brand superhero movie about
some other kid with spider-based powers
in which
case this movie is great and i'm sure
regardless if this film is mediocre or
amazing
16 year old girls will cry and squeal in
the theater when tom and zendaya kiss
because this series has become the
modern twilight and there are people
with no social lives who obsess over
which shirt tom is wearing in his
selfies
and can give you a complete run down of
every article of clothing in his closet
because that's useful and interesting
information
people who don't read comic books will
say no matter what that it's the
greatest spider-man film ever and it's
super accurate but also being accurate
doesn't matter
and it has no flaws at all and lmao
imagine thinking homecoming had no
emotional weight
screenshot of peter parker looking sad
because he didn't impress iron man
those kinds of fans are just as bad as
snyder cut people arguably worse because
they get what they want
constantly and feel validated and smug
instead of just pining for something
imaginary
they're certainly as bad as the raimi
suit people but they'll say
why do you gotta single us out for toxic
behavior every fandom has its flaws
people on both sides are in the wrong as
if a person robbing a bank should just
point to another guy robbing a liquor
store down the street and say
you can't arrest me he's doing something
bad too am i
cynical and just beaten down by
obnoxious fans and their inability to
take criticism or think critically about
something they like
yes will it matter in 15 years when
spider-man is rebooted again with a new
actor
god i hope not hey it's scott aka a
little cheddar and i did this i
edited it xavier please pay me i spent
all my money on switch stuff
um if you want to watch my videos
here they are um they're pretty good
these are just free videos i thought you
would like
yeah i know you i know you live i'm
gonna cut that that's not funny
uh but i want to take the space to also
talk about my friend
the worst critic who made this this and
this wow
he also said this funny jokes venom such
a complete trash fire
can it be fixed will a woman ever suck
my penis before i die
isn't he funny anyway you should
actually watch his channel because
it's tiny and it's pathetic and i think
he might kill himself
if he doesn't blow up so uh yeah please
check him out too
okay thank you love you
[Music]
you